hey you know I am I am starting to think
that when congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green apologized for comparing things to
the Holocaust it may not have been a
completely sincere apology because she
is yet again saying that things Joe
Biden is doing are like the Nazis
um the uh Business Insider is reporting
Marjorie Taylor green Compares Biden's
vaccine push to Nazis weeks after
apologizing for comparing mask mandates
to the Holocaust congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green compared Biden's
vaccination push to the Nazi Brown
Shirts this came weeks after she
apologized for comparing other covid-19
guidelines to the Nazis that was when
she said Nancy Pelosi saying you have to
wear masks on the house floor
uh is uh is is I guess like you know
have the Jews were treated by Nazis
Greene has a history of promoting
anti-semitic conspiracy theories let's
uh take a look at the Tweet she sent out
where she uh responded to Joe Biden
saying we've got to go Community to
community we've got to go neighborhood
by neighborhood we've got to go door to
door and just say hey do you want to get
vaccinated Marjorie Taylor green
tweeting Biden pushing a vaccine that's
not FDA approved shows kovid is a
political tool used to control people
people have a choice they don't need
your medical Brown Shirts showing up at
their door ordering vaccinations of
course nobody would be ordering it they
would just be making it really really
easy to get one hey we're here do you
want a vaccine here you go you can't
force people to be part of the human
experiment and even that is sort of
alluding to Nazi medical experiments
um come on guys come on and if you have
forgotten or didn't see it this is
Marjorie Taylor green just a few weeks
ago realizing that the Holocaust was
really bad and she was wrong to compare
Nancy Pelosi to the Holocaust okay uh
take a look at that always
always find everyone
very much a normal person
I think it's important for me to always
be transparent and and honest
and I just want to tell you all I'm
really really lucky uh I was blessed
with I am blessed with amazing parents
and my dad just passed away in April
but I will say he taught me some great
things and one of the best lessons that
my father always taught me was when you
make a mistake
I have made a mistake and it's really
bothered me for a couple of weeks now
so I definitely want to own it this
afternoon I visited the Holocaust Museum
the Holocaust is
there's nothing comparable to it it's
it's
it happened and you know over 6 million
Jewish people were murdered more than
that there were not just Jewish people
black people
Christians all kinds of children
people that that the Nazis didn't
believe were good enough or perfect
enough and the horrors of the Holocaust
are something that some people don't
even believe happened and some people
deny but there is no comparison to the
Holocaust and there are words that I
have said in remarks that I've made that
I know are offensive and for that I want
to apologize
and I am I am just fine and very glad to
be able to come out here and do that
because I believe
it
I believe that if we're going to leave
we need to be able to lead in a way
where if we've messed up it's very
important for us to say we're sorry so
you know that clearly her apology was
insincere clearly this is a very very
sick woman clearly this is someone who
just can't get away from these
comparisons to Nazis and the Holocaust
and all of this stuff but there is sort
of an interesting conflict here because
Marjorie Taylor green is a massive Trump
suck-up I mean absolutely one of the
biggest but she's constantly doing
anti-vax stuff but remember Trump said
not that long ago quote it's a great
vaccine
it's a safe vaccine and it's something
that works I recommend it to a lot of
people that don't want to get it and a
lot of those people voted for me that
was Trump saying that even recognizing
that there's lots of anti-vax among his
supporters what would Marjorie Taylor
green a massive and uh bottomless Trump
suck up say about the fact that her
leader Donald Trump is saying hey even
the people who follow me and don't want
it they should go ahead and get it and
they're just continuing to push this
type of thing here is Charlie Kirk who's
sort of like uh young young Republican
group leader this group called Turning
Point USA Charlie Kirk just compared
vaccination guidelines to apartheid but
more than anything else Tucker what we
are going to do is a massive public
relations campaign and make sure
students know they are not alone they
don't have to hide in the shadows all of
a sudden they're concerned that if they
get the vaccine they're going to be
treated as if there's there's something
I said this earlier and this is a big
statement but it's almost this apartheid
style open-air hostage situation like oh
you can have your freedom back if you
get the jab this is unacceptable we're
gonna fight back against it yeah so
again you know they they just can't get
away from this stuff what's interesting
about the Charlie Kirk thing is that I
have been warning not as something that
we want to divide people but it's
something that is simply going to happen
if you continue seeing such vaccination
rate gaps between Democrats and
Republicans between liberals and
conservatives between Biden voters and
Trump voters this is going to turn into
a republican pandemic now of course
because the VIR the the vaccine is not
100 effective even if every Democrat got
vaccinated and very few Republicans did
some Democrats are still going to get
sick you only have 92 percent protection
maybe even slightly lower against the
Delta variant we still don't know the
level of protection against the Lambda
variant but there is no doubt that that
vaccination Gap is going to start
infecting more and more Republicans than
it is Democrats if it's the Republicans
who overwhelmingly are refusing to go
and get themselves vaccinated so sort of
inadvertently
stumbling Charlie Kirk did across a
mathematical reality that if the
Republicans are the ones who were not
protected they are the ones who are
overwhelmingly going to get sick and
they are overwhelmingly the ones who are
going to die
was Marjorie Taylor Green's apology
sincere let me know you can find me on
Twitter at dpacman I think the answer is
obviously no I think it got to the point
where even for her level of tolerating
being critiqued uh and criticized she
realized I should probably apologize for
this but then within days really going
right back to the same analogies and
allusions to Nazis and the Holocaust and
Hitler just disgusting completely
disgusting stuff uh let's take a quick
break we've got a packed show for you uh
we'll be right back
one of our sponsors today is Helix sleep
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about Helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you I took the Sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what I needed I often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and I've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all Helix mattresses come
with a 10 year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
I think you will all of my viewers will
get up to 200 off your order and you'll
get two super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video